et ça me les tiennent donc il ya deux
candidates vrai il ya john eledjam et
mokhtar qui sont de faux candidats
regardez le questions pour un champion
je pense que ça va vous plaire regarde
[Musique]
comment ça va ça va très bien son
professeur de maths
oui apicultrice ce nom comme votre
t-shirt me laisse penser d'ailleurs to
be or not to be
oui avery ou deux seulement il est sympa
se déchire tout vous est venue cette
passion pour l'apiculture
mais en fait papa a bien envie
d'installer une ruche dans son jardin
comme il a très peur des abeilles c'est
moi qui ont su qu en soit merci d'être
avec nous et bonne chance à faire soit
rejoué ensemble et quelques mois oui si
heureux de retrouver bon sens pour ce
soir bonjour d'ailleurs si vous le nom
du kebab de shoki shoki c2t bab lourd
kebab de lula ça c'est bon à la danse
c'est vous qui va trouver non enfin mis
d'accord
et alors justement là vous jouez avec
nous mais qui tient le kebab c'est mon
cousin malheureusement pourquoi c'est
mon coup ça n'est pas très confiance en
lui ah bon pourquoi vous êtes vous déjà
chauffé ce qu'on sente vous avez confié
votre kebab à votre cousin qui vit dans
la caisse se sont d'accord c'est un
match important que je trouvais bon rôle
embrasse quand même vous offrir un petit
frisson tomates oignons c'est pour moi
d'accord ok super m ce qu'ils veulent
sans s'asseoir narcy benoît très bien
passionné de littérature de poésie d'un
auteur en partie l'idée du 19e et du 20e
siècle
victor hogo en particulier un poème
préféré peut-être demain dès l'aube
benoît pour bien se concentrer du coup
me sentais quelques notes merci il faut
qu'ils écoutent en jeu c'est chaud qui
c'est plutôt le rap mais je suis sûr que
ça va vous plaire mais je jure que je
crois ne va adorer ma chanson choquera
zouk explique d'abord c'est raté merci
donc à suivre
bon c'est pas fins d'accords demain dès
l'aube à l'heure où tu es sans la
campagne je partirai battue je sais que
tu m'as temps j'irais par la force
j'irai par la montagne depuis le marché
loin de toi plus longtemps c'est
magnifique on a des candidats font mieux
que ce soir c'est pour vous avoir tous
les cas je pense qu'on va passer un bon
moment
attendez j'ai l'impression que sookie
envie de chanter
vous êtes jaloux de benoît cessa
appartement qu'est ce que vous voulez me
sentais sookie pas dur à passer avec mon
groupe en fait j'ai un groupe ça fait
les caténaires
comme l'indiquent les cratères venez
avec moi ce qu'il veut ajouté
monfort de veste ce soir est donc nous
offre un tir après bordeaux publique
touche
[Applaudissements]
je pense pas je sais pas qui est son
bras chambon ça veut dire sookie ktrc
votre collectif car deux magnifiques
candidats ce soir c'est une émission
avec une belle ambiance qui s'annonce et
on commence par les neuf fois gagnant
[Applaudissements]
françois d'anvers ou qui benoît ouvrent
au buzzer que ce soit première question
à 1 point en france de combien de temps
maximum un automobiliste est concerné
dérangère 12,12 points peut-il disposés
sur son permis de conduire récemment suu
kyi pardon je savais en 2014 dans quels
titres tirent aussi le prix de la
meilleure soupe qui country panneaux
mais il est trop fort
color britanno comment vous avez deviné
est ce que vous allez me demander
et puis non mais l'incroyable question
rendue kg aussi en ondes à fans de kenge
aussi est pour vous un extrait
cinq points d'avancé km h au pij est en
train de mettre le feu aux questions
pour un super champion
[Applaudissements]
tu l'homme maintenant qu'elle n'emporte
la partie molle et charnue sookie
l'attelage est énorme mais doit excuser
séraphin j'ai pas fait exprès de buzz et
enfin je suis un peu sidéré quoi pas de
souci c'est normal de minutes un joueur
qui joue qui je pense est du coup je
pensais au coup d'envoi
ça fait 15 ans je regarde l'émission
j'ai encore jamais vu ça mais mettre des
tops un peu partout je trouve ça un
petit peu là excusez moi on se concentre
sur le jeu
je sais que suu kyi va faire un effort
pour l'inviter les les noms qui fâchent
d'accord en mathématiques écoutez bien
que vous x dans l'équation 11x +11 égale
8 est une bonne réponse
pas bon montrer des filtres a
effectivement c'est un souci pointe
quelle variété de chico chauffe finement
dentelée pendant ses cours et le
pissenlit pas de navettes et non non on
évite les petites provocations à
l'oreille quand sa maman c'est juste que
je n'en croyais pas mes genoux qui l'ont
bien entendu c'est une frange des cils à
l'issue de mon talent concentré du même
mois gecina ou à pékin je suis tabou je
sens je pense qu'on peut passer un bon
moment
bien sûr si on y met tous j'ai concentré
mon grand amour mal parti mais football
quel milieu défensif né en 1970 sans
nouvelle calédonie a remporté en mai
mais l'histoire était soutenance a
commencé un petit peu à me taper sur le
système excusez moi de vous dire moi je
suis fan de cette émission je suis pas
venu ici pour qu'on rigole et l'équipage
et compagnie tout ça stoppe en noir de
merde
nous devrons merde non merde chabal du
magal c'est un peu le côté sébastien
chabal du maghreb c'est marrant deux
minutes mais pas
la menace la notion tiennent ce week-end
yamada des valeurs monsieur kenya
menaces dont benoît benoît et menaces
rodez
vous êtes à vous mais
[Musique]
je vous dise ce qu'ils écoutent et moi
moi je pars la bonne humeur mais ce que
j'apprécie restent respectivement ce que
voulait dire que malgré vos élèves
pardon excusez moi vous comprenez tout
pardon pour trois points dans les profs
1 et 2 quel jeune humoriste en
caoutchouc qui étaient bonnes réponses
sutil 7e
oui
non ça va
et ma maman kulm enfin sous qui vous
qualifiant premier premier témoin à
partir de maintenant que vous ne
perturbe réfugiés d'autres candidats
sinon on ne peut pas apprécier vos
performances au groupe onet rodez métier
la prochaine sera un produit
ma prochaine sa part suki vous amuser
autant vous voulez avec moi moi je suis
là pour ça et c'est ok mais pas avec les
autres candidats d'accord ce qu'il faut
pas les perturber
ok ça marche je suis sûr qu'on va
pouvoir jouer tranquillement
quel peuple nomade du phare benoît les
trois gains benoît vous êtes qualifiés
pour le gain sera la suite allez-y alesi
benoît voilà retrouvez votre ami chouki
tout va bien se passer
benoît super bravo voilà ça c'est beau
voilà j'aime les poignées de main et jeu
et je compte sur vous pour maintenir ce
niveau d'excellence jusqu'au bout on
joue maintenant aux quatre à la suite
sookie c'est vous qui choisissez votre
thème en pro b qui ne tardera je ne suis
pas être étonné que je suis tout petit
et pas la douleur en poésie c'est assez
hasardeux de france hélas oui il était
bien présent pour la pression car les
chaussures un peu contre lyon ou encore
en sa faveur notamment l arase air et la
poésie non ça vous inspire et moi j'ai
le sang
tout y est passionné de rap
passionné de photos aussi j'en ai donné
500 quel type de photos que de se fier
que des photos de vous quoi sookie
d'argent en 2003 quel rappeur américain
signe la musique du film take my dans
lequel il lui même au bois j'ai vu
fixette
le dit choqué par ce match 6 4 à la
suite sous qui pourrait bien cher pour
voir si je ne dirais pas des fois c'est
benoît regarder loin devant françoise
ans je suis pas seul stop ans qui joue
du rendez vous
j'ai plutôt figée
stop
ou qui s'il vous plaît france pascal
postes 2 et là je peux le refaire toutes
pièces le moment arrêter sinon on s'en
sort pas quoi vous a dit de remettre en
cause de son cap et quentin benoît fait
les arts martiaux ça me ça me donne la
concentration n'est pas annoncée benoît
soit la galerie des glaces à versailles
la douleur en poésie ou le tlm mystère
je vais prendre la douleur employé chez
rené benoit rousseau avec moi à la
partie arrêtez de concept qui les met en
position met en condition de shaolin des
gens partout du rock et folk
vous vous avancez et le sublime retourné
avec moi voilà c'est bon là ça me
comment ça allait arriver dans ce clip
commence à ce qui ce qu'il veut nous
faisait deux fois qu'on lui dit qu'est
ce que c'est tout ça mais noir oui a
conduit derrière gruyère retard
mais sa maladie dont benoît retourne et
là s'il vous plaît c'est moi qui vais
bouffer al cantara week end à rome la
télé réalité
non mais faut quelque chose ça ferait
tourner sécurité bordel ou quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des formula
le problème je vais te dire mon chéri
s'écoute avec moctar bien sûr mais lui
aussi sa faute on dit là bas
voilà donc en fait honte à piéger deux
fois deux fois tu es formidable merci au
public aussi merci merci mon coeur
balance
[Applaudissements]